في تقريرنا لموقع سين بي سي الاقتصاديه
يكشف كاتبه انه امضي خمس سنوات في اجراء
مقابلات مع اكثر من 200
مليارا ليعرف سر نجاحهم وتوصل لست عادات
رئيسيه يقول تقرير ان اصحاب الملايين
يتعلمون باستمرار
94% منهم افادوا بانهم استغرقوا بضع دقائق
كل يوم لتعلم كلمات جديده واحد و 60% منهم
مارسوا مهارات جديده لمده لا تقل عن
ساعتين في اليوم رياضه مثلا او الاستماع
ايضا الاثرياء يستمعون اكثر مما يتحدثون
ومتوسط النسبه اظهر استماعهم خمس دقائق
مقابل التحدث لدقيقه واحده وقال واحد
وثمانون بالمئه منهم انهم يسمعون دائما
يسعون للاستماع لتعليقات الاخ
اصحاب الملايين يبنون فرقا عظيمه 86 منهم
يعملون بمعدل 50 ساعه او اكثر اسبوعيا لكن
الاهم هو العمل مع فريق يعوض نقاط ضعفهم
من وقت وطاقه عقليه او جسديه وتقول هذه
الدراسه ان اصحاب الملايين يهتمون ايضا
بصحتهم ويبتعدون عن السهر والاهم يقراون
المخاطر الماليه ولا يورطون انفسهم فيها